[Music]
while in Armenia Sona and I were asked
to appear on some of the country's most
popular talk shows
oh my god she's driving me home but what
I really wanted was to book a dramatic
role on one of their soap operas okay
this is very exciting
word got out that I'm here in Yerevan in
Armenia and I was immediately offered
the role in a soap opera called UDC ho
keen which roughly translates through
other sol very popular Armenian soap
opera I've shown up I'm on location I'm
to play a gangster and the director just
met with me and he told me that my job
is to watch my goons beat up a guy and I
get to smoke a cigar this is gonna be
fun
I will be dating a co-star that is my
habit when I have a film role she will
become my lover for the duration of the
shoot which i think is about 15 minutes
it is also my duration
[Applause]
okay I will change clothes get ready to
play my role excellent thank you
[Music]
[Music]
they're just okay we're off to
[Applause]
that's the time I'm here
fine blend in and now I just have to
figure out when the Armenian enemies are
booked flight hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy japanese
pornography